Dwayne The Rock Johnson has promised the
hierarchy of power is about to change in
the dceu but who exactly is Black Adam
and how does he fit into the series
timeline here's everything we know about
this anti-heroes history and his future
warning spoilers ahead here we go
possibly the oldest DC EU character to
date Black Adam was born 5 000 years ago
likely predating even Wonder Woman's
birth teth Adam began as a slave of the
fictional country conduct where he lost
his son who died saving his father in
the comics the wizard Shazam grants teth
Adam the powers of gods not knowing that
the former slave holds no restraint in
delivering deadly Justice to his abusers
in Black Adam's original comic book
origin from faucet Comics which takes
place before the character was acquired
by DC he destroys the Pharaoh and condox
Elite before claiming the throne for
himself
after black Adam's Rampage in condoc the
Wizard realizes his mistake in bestowing
teth Adam with the powers of gods unable
to remove his powers Shazam renames the
violent being Black Adam and banishes
him from the world of mankind in the
original faucet origin the wizard
teleports Black Adam to the other side
of the universe forcing the villain to
spend the next 5 000 years flying back
to Earth however the film's teaser shows
the wizard Shazam using his magic to
seemingly entomb Black Adam for
thousands of years giving him time to
find a new champion in the modern day
humans free the demigod who awakens in a
Strange New World
by the time Black Adam escapes his tomb
the citizens of the dceu have already
experienced plenty of bizarre and
dangerous threats aliens from Krypton
tried to destroy the world a beast known
as doomsday nearly destroyed metropolis
and killed Superman Atlantean armies
fought over whether or not to destroy
life on the surface world the
enchantress nearly toppled Midway City a
giant starfish named staro visited
Terror upon Cordo Maltese and alien
butterflies threatened to take over the
world thankfully Humanity lives in an
era of superheroes who can combat such
threats HBO Max's Peacemaker series
offers a clue as to when Black Adam
emerges into this age of Heroes in the
fourth episode the anti-hero Vigilante
gets himself arrested to get thrown into
prison and kill peacemaker's father in a
courtyard where guards are having lunch
one guard is seen reading a newspaper
with an article indicating an
organization known as intergang has
seized power in the nation of Conduct in
DC Comics intergang is a criminal
organization that uses Advanced Weaponry
obtained from the alien planet
apocalypse to further their agenda since
Black Adam considers himself the
protector of conduct once he returns
he'll definitely want to have a few
words with inner Gang This suggests
Black Adam will occur sometime after
Peacemaker
in comic book lore there have been
several versions of Black Adam and his
origins in Shazam volume 1 written by DC
Comics Maestro Jeff Johns we learned
Black Adam is imprisoned by the wizard
in a tomb for his evil Deeds much like
in the movie while researching the
villain shazam's current champion Billy
Batson gets a glimpse into the past and
Witnesses a boy named Amman trying to
survive oppression along with his uncle
the boy is given Powers by the wizard
Shazam and Billy incorrectly assumes
Amman becomes Black Adam however he
later learns amman's Uncle steals his
nephew's power kills the Wizard's
intended champion and transforms into
Black Adam in the Modern Age Dr Savannah
uncovers the entrance to Black Adam's
prison he says the magic word Shazam and
freeze Black Adam who goes in search of
Billy Batson in an attempt to defeat him
and become the ultimate Champion the new
DC EU film makes changes to the comic
book origin focusing on teth Adam's
relationship with his son not his nephew
the movie also doesn't feature Shazam or
his young counterpart to he bouncing
however Black Adam does get released
from his magical prison to bring his
brand of Justice down on those he deems
deserving of his rage this puts him in
conflict with many of Earth's Heroes
including some new faces
black Adam's primary antagonists will be
the Justice Society of America the JSA
is a group of Heroes who came together
during DC's golden age of comics in the
1940s in many DC continuities the JSA
predates the Justice League and clashed
with the enemies of its era including
the tyrannical Nazi regime while JSA
members have all appeared in modern
Comics the JSA is typically recognized
as a superhero team from a classic ERA
with much older Heroes only thing we can
learn from these geezers is how to add
more fiber to our diets the JSA includes
famous members such as the original
flash Jay Garrick as well as the first
human Green Lantern Alan Scott however
Black Adam will focus on other JSA
members including Hawkman Dr Fate Adam
Smasher and Cyclone how these Heroes
came to be in the DC EU is unknown
unlike Superman or Wonder Woman we
haven't received an origin tale for any
of these Heroes however if they're
anything like their comic book
counterparts Dr 8 and Hawkman are both
born from ancient Powers Dr Fate is the
creation of a cosmic deity while Hawkman
was the Egyptian prince Khufu who after
being killed with a mystical dagger is
bound to be reincarnated upon death
during the JSA era Hawkman is reborn as
Carter Hall who adopts the mantle of
Hawkman using alien anti-gravity and
metal to power his armor and weaponry as
for atom smasher he's the heroic
grandson of the super villain cyclotron
in the comics gifted with super strength
and the ability to control the size and
density of his body meanwhile Cyclone is
the granddaughter of the original Red
Tornado and possesses the powers of
flight wind control and sound wave
control both are Legacy Heroes with
strong ties to the JSA
Black Adam occurs primarily in the
modern day after the events of the
theatrical released Justice League this
means the JSA and Justice League coexist
in the same era however this doesn't
explain why the JSA are the only Heroes
who seem to be responding to the
climactic events after Black Adam
emerges from his prison while the
Justice League took some time to come
together its individual members have
been active for years cal-el revealed
himself years ago as Superman while
Black Adam was still stuck in limbo
Wonder Woman made herself known to
humanity during the first world war
Bruce Wayne has been operating as Batman
for decades and both Aquaman and the
Flash had superhero careers long before
joining the Justice League the greater
dceu is familiar with these rock stars
but the JSA still seems relatively
unknown it'll be interesting to see how
the timelines link up and learn what the
Justice League is doing when Black Adam
makes himself known notably Amanda
Waller from dceu's suicide Squad films
is working with the JSA and has some
pull with Certain Justice League members
including a certain famous Kryptonian
empowered by the gods themselves Black
Adam is an insanely powerful being and
what better way to show this by having
him challenge the alpha of DC
Superheroes Superman in DC Comics Black
Adam has always been a formidable Foe
for powerhouses like Superman and Shazam
notably aside from Kryptonite Superman
is vulnerable to Magic something Black
Adam can produce punishing amounts of
thanks to his Divine gifts after a
Twitter fan expressed a desire to see
these two Titans come together Johnson
retweeted the message and shared that he
always aims to listen to his audience I
hear you and I always got you state of
the Rock in the film's mid-credits scene
we see Johnson make good on his promise
after being informed by Amanda Waller
that he is not to leave condox borders
Black Adam arrogantly informs her that
no one can stop him from doing what he
wants in response Waller sends Superman
to confront Black Adam who informs the
demigod that they should talk no word on
whether or not this will lead to a big
screen battle between the two but with
Henry Cavill back in the Superman suit
will likely be seeing more of both the
hero and the anti-hero
Shazam and Black Adam are like the Joker
and Batman young Billy Batson as the
all-powerful hero Shazam seeks to do
good and uphold a heroic standard Black
Adam doesn't live by a code of any kind
his goal is singular in his mind and no
Act is too amoral or dicey if it
furthers his objective of obliterating
tyranny and opposition yet despite these
moral differences Shazam and Black Adam
are ultimately two sides of the same
coin imbued with Godly Powers by the
same wizard in the comics the wizard saw
the error of his ways and banished Black
Adam until a hero could be called
forward to defeat him with the rise of
Billy Batson and Shazam that time had
come however this is a film focused on
the bad guy a move meant to position
Black Adam as a sympathetic anti-hero
Shazam is nowhere to be seen and
director John McCool at Sarah said not
to expect a Shazam Black Adam match up
just yet in an interview with variety he
stated our movie is an original story by
the time the movie ends he doesn't know
who she Shazam where Superman is however
it's fairly certain that Black Adam
takes place after the first Shazam film
if Black Adam were around during the
events of Shazam he would have most
certainly confronted Billy over his
powers Black Adam doesn't want a
champion standing in the way of his
goals and wants to be a supreme power
eliminating Shazam is the only means to
that end the two will inevitably meet in
the DCU however even if it isn't in
Black Adam's first outing it's Destiny
while Shazam won't appear in Black Adam
audiences will be seeing Billy Batson's
super powered alter ego very soon Shazam
Fury of the Gods is set to release in
March 2023 just a couple of months after
Black Adam instead of Black Adam however
the sequel will feature a wildly new
antagonist in the form of Helen mirren's
espera a jealous God seeking the power
of Shazam for herself with Black Adam
busy contending with intergang and
kondok and Shazam working with his
family to dispel evil on the other side
of the world in Philly it's it's
unlikely that these two will come to
blows it also remains to be seen if
either film will tease a future Clash or
if either character cameos in the
opposite film from a timeline
perspective however consider these films
either happening concurrently or
relatively close together allowing the
two Champions to remain separate for now
with the future of the Justice League up
in the air there may be a brand new
world for Black Adam to conquer in the
dceu Ben Affleck is wrapping up his time
as Batman with the upcoming The Flash
movie it's hard to believe Ray Fisher
will be back in cyborg anytime soon
after his Feud with Warner Brothers and
the Flash as portrayed by Ezra Miller
will almost definitely not return
outside of his solo project after the
actor's various alleged crimes meanwhile
Wonder Woman is primed for a third film
rounding out a Trilogy for the Amazonian
Warrior Aquaman and the lost kingdom is
also in the works while Henry cavill's
involvement is Superman and future DC EU
movies has been confirmed with that
post-credits scene with Black Adam about
to make his Mark in the dceu could
Johnson's take on the man in Black be
the one that leads us into the future of
dceu the remaining Heroes Aquaman Wonder
Woman Shazam and whoever from the JSA
survives Black Adam could use a central
hero or a unifying villain the film
universe is on the precipice of a
shake-up as Warner Brothers other seems
bent on abandoning what Zack Snyder
began with a leading man like Johnson
Anything is Possible
[Music]